I think people also over over think what
meditation is right because I think like
does it have to be in like like explain
kind of like how you meditate on a
day-to-day basis meditate I mean I can
meditate whenever throughout the day
it's just simple
breeding out through the mouth and it's
just simply focusing on it like just
keep focusing on it and the more you
focus on on that that sense of breathing
the deeper you get and the more in
Rhythm you get with Earth
um a lot of people can never really get
into Rhythm because they never took a
deep breath they never really you know
some people bring breathe wrong too some
people bring breathe in through their
mouth and out through their nose my
French Bulldog breathe is wrong he
doesn't have a choice though so um yeah
to be able to just be able to get your
breathing right focus on your breathing
and on deep meditations I do those a lot
like if I'm about to lay down
um and I just lay down and focus on my
breathing and people say I think about
this I think about that we'll just count
how many seconds it took for you to
inhale and count how many seconds it
took for your exhale and that'll help
you focus on your breathing because your
mind is now counting have you done Yoga
Yoga yeah I've done yoga how's that
um it's beautiful I don't do it too much
but um it's for sure like one of those
things that's needed to try and my wife
does hot yoga and I always ask her like
how many people are in the room because
I like 20. I'm like what if someone
farts in them
I just rather do it at the crib alone
you know what I mean but it's crazy